hey what's going on people i'm dave
rubin this is the reuben report direct
message for april 26
2021 as always click subscribe if you're
watching on youtube that's the only
place we live stream these at least for
now and tap that notification bell so
that maybe you see our videos in
your youtube video feed we've got
four stories for you and before we get
to them i just want to say
i'm feeling very good today i had a very
relaxing
restful weekend i did not do any
politics
i actually posted on our locals
community guys let's talk about anything
this weekend
other than politics so we were doing
food we were doing music a lot of people
growing vegetables and fruit and gardens
and people were going horseback riding
and i posted a video
we actually david made a lack a rack of
lamb
and we got a smoker like one of these
things where you actually put like the
chips in
then you smoke it and kind of keep it in
this big bell jar
we're just eating good stuff and there's
good stuff happening over there so if
you haven't joined us yet i recommend
you check it out you can sign up for a
free account
and just see what we're doing and then
if you pay a couple bucks if you want to
interact it's reubenreport.locals.com
and we got four stories for you today
first off we are in a children's reality
show because
this video that we're going to show you
from white house press secretary jen
pasaki uh is just absolutely ridiculous
it's
actually from friday where as she
wrapped up the press conference
she gave cookies to all the reporters
and it's it's i'm just going to show you
because it's such
children nonsense masquerading as
journalism
masquerading as professionalism and
everything else just ridiculous
then of course although we are past the
george floyd
uh verdict then obviously derek chovin
the officer was found
guilty and of course there still were
riots and we haven't really
solved anything uh there is george floyd
square in minneapolis and now there are
signs popping up
with special rules for white people i
know you losers at media matters are
watching this right now saying
oh what's dave going to say about rules
against white people this week well
the george floyd square people have
special rules for white people which
in my world is known as racism we'll get
to that oh and then you know one of the
things that the progressives always talk
about guys
fifteen dollar minimum wage gotta pay uh
everybody fifteen dollars even though
there's no market reasons to do it or
you as an individual businessman could
decide to do whatever you want and pay
people how you see fit and the more that
you know you let the market work then
wages rise and you know
kind of thomas hull stuff uh well
chipotle is now coming out and saying
that this 15
minimum wage situation is gonna cause a
uh
price increase across the board on those
delicious chipotle burrito bowls so
we'll talk about that
and then surprise surprise coveted
numbers continue
to drop in florida and in texas which
are completely open
and they are going up in places like
michigan
and they're just sort of sitting at the
same level here
in california and new york so we're
going to get to all of that there's no
science behind any of it and if a year
and a half later you don't see it
already people
then i've got a little science kit i'd
like to sell you before we do any of
that
i want to talk to you about something
delicious
you know i like the red wine people well
here's a tip next time you grill up
a couple steaks which we also did this
weekend pop open a bottle of extreme
altitude
malbec wine it comes from these remote
vineyards in argentina located
up at around 9000 feet when these
vintners aren't making wine they're
herding cattle so they know
meat they know barbecue and that's what
these malbecs are for
as soon as you open up the bottle you're
going to experience delicious notes of
blackberry leather smoke and little dark
cherry you're also going to get less
sugar
less chemicals and less additives and 10
times more resveratrol which is a
powerful
longevity booster we actually cracked
open this very bottle right here
got a few of them this weekend as we
knocked out a rib eye
the guys over at freethinkerwine.com
just got a special shipment of these
wines in they've got
one malbec from the third highest
vineyard in the world at 8
950 feet that's high visit
freethinkerwine.com today and you'll get
50
off all of the wine and 50 off shipping
this is a small batch and it's going to
go fast
just visit freethinkerwine.com
that's freethinkerwine.com and now back
to me okay
let's go to the white house press
conference
joe biden has only given one press
conference in over two months of being
president
but jen pasake does these little theater
things pretty much every day
she is the white house press secretary
and when she's not giving nonsensical
answers or saying that she's going to
circle back to things
or just generally being a very poor
representative of the united states
government
she's giving cookies to the press take a
look um
great well thank everyone as i promised
yesterday i promised snacks
um i did not bring them in here but my
mother-in-law made homemade chocolate
chip cookies
for you guys so there's one for each of
you in here we will do it in a covered
safe way
um but thanks everyone and have a great
weekend
thank you i promised snacks my
mother-in-law made homemade cookies and
we're gonna do it in a copic safeway
like does this seem like a serious
government that we have and let's just
pretend
for a moment that the previous
administration had done this right like
if kaley who i think was a spectacular
white house press secretary actually and
had to deal with the hostile press
this woman has to basically deal with
people going down on her every day
so imagine though if uh kaylee had done
that we're gonna give you cookies the
media would have said trump's trying to
poison the press corps with
his cookies and blah blah blah like you
get it you get it anyway i just thought
the reason i want to show that is it's
like it's not that important the scheme
of things but it shows you sort of
the dumbing down of everything like the
press
and politicians are supposed to be at
odds in a way you could argue that
having a press that hated trump
was was healthier than what we have
right now because
at least you know they were going after
the administration
these people not only are they not going
after the administration i mean how many
in in two plus months three plus months
of his presidency how many
negative articles have been written
about joe biden anywhere
actually if you read pretty much all the
articles everything they do is spinning
everything he does positively no matter
how negative it is
in reality and then still going after
the republicans for pouncing or
other such crazy things that the
republicans do they pounce on things all
the time
but just this like i promise snacks and
you're gonna get
snacks like is this a serious
government like there's serious stuff
there's some sort of pandemic and we
have to wear 18 masks and we can't see
our families
till july 4th and we've got economic
problems
and all sorts of other things are
happening but
alas you'll have cookies and the way
that they oh my god thank
you thank you for the cookies
thank you for and even and are these
good or they're going to do it in a
covered safe way but i'm sure people are
touching things and they're touching
things
and she didn't have a mask it's all such
spectacular [ __ ] we are in
a children's reality show remember it
and then you'll be able to watch these
things with a bit of a smile on your
face
all right i want to talk to you guys
about bambi you know when running a
business hr issues can kill you
wrongful termination suits minimum wage
requirements labor regulations the list
goes on and on
and hr manager salaries aren't cheap at
an average of 70
000 a year bambi spelled b-a-m-b-e
was created specifically for small
business you can get a dedicated hr
manager craft hr policy and maintain
your compliance all for just 99
a month with bamba you can transform hr
from your biggest liability to your
greatest strength
your dedicated hr manager is available
by phone email or real-time
chat from onboarding determinations they
customize your policies to fit your
business and help you manage your
employees day-to-day
all for just 99 bucks a month month to
month no hidden fees cancel any time
if you're like me then i bet you didn't
start your business because you wanted
to spend all of your time on hr
compliance
let bambi help get your free hr audit
today go to bambi.com
reuben right now to schedule your free
hr audit that's bambi.com
ruben spelled bam to the
dot com slash reuben and now back to me
all right
so you know obviously last week the the
big story was the guilty verdict
in the derek chovin trial he was the
police officer that was convicted
of killing george floyd i think we've
sort of moved past that already i mean
the way things move isn't it isn't it
sort of extraordinary
even me talking about this now five six
days later barely
is it even five six days later four days
later like things just move so quickly
that we'll just kind of forget that one
because
what happened right as that verdict was
coming in was
uh the police officer who shot the
knife-wielding maniac and killed her
and then everybody went crazy about that
and we talked about that how lebron
was basically targeting that police
officer who of course did the right
thing
saved a young girl's life but then the
entire woke left and the entire
establishment in essence was saying that
the police officer was wrong
when you know had she literally beheaded
the other girl she had a huge cleaver
had she beheaded
that other girl you wouldn't have heard
anything about it certainly from lebron
and it wouldn't have made the news
because it would have been black on
black crime it wouldn't have fit the
narrative
and we can go from there okay the point
is that that story
just kind of kicked the george floyd
story away but there still is
george floyd's square in minneapolis and
they have
certain instructions that they've placed
outside
for people that are entering so we're
going to show you the
image here and i'm going to read you
some of the some of the real gems
on this thing now of course at top it
says welcome to george floyd square it's
a sacred space for community public
grief and protest that all sounds
just fine and they're doing it here why
well this is where george floyd took his
last breath
under the knee of a minneapolis police
officer under the watch of three other
officers okay and now derek chovin was
convicted
of that crime uh but then as you can see
here
i've circled it on my paper for white
people
in particular and this is some of the
stuff that they want white people to do
when they enter
this place they want you to de-center
yourself
and come to listen learn mourn and
witness
remember you are here to support not be
supported
you are less than white person and you
better accept it also i'm not a decenter
yourself i don't even know exactly what
that means
but okay and you're here to support not
be supported so you know bring coffee
for these people bring them donuts
and give them more stuff okay why not
just give them cash
uh the second one is not terrible you
know mindful about your volume pace and
movements we don't want to startle
people
okay i don't know why that only applies
to white people you know you know white
people with their sudden movement
movements all the time you know
then next seek to contribute to the
energy of the space
rather than drain it bring your own
processing to other white folks so that
you will not
harm bipac that's black indigenous and
people of color
bring your own processing to other white
folks i mean these are just words that
they string together
as if they have any particular meaning
and then of course
if you witness white folks doing
problematic things
speak up with compassion to take the
burden off black folks
and our siblings of color whenever
appropriate seek to engage rather than
escalate so that it can be a learning
moment
rather than a disruption yes watch out
and keep note
of those white people because other
white people even if you've decentered
yourself
and done all the problematic stuff so
you're in a straitjacket there
there could be other white people uppity
white people speaking up and sharing
their thoughts
or speaking loudly or maybe even moving
their hands these people must be taken
out and dealt with
anyway i think you see what's going on
here we are
training and we are promoting the idea
that based on the color of your skin you
should actually behave
a certain way it's not just that we
should give benefits
to certain people now based on the color
of their skin or punish
other people based on the color of their
skin asians at harvard
and now in canada i posted this this
morning uh they are quite literally in
ontario giving
out vaccines based on color of skin
this is also happening uh up in seattle
uh which we covered the other day as
well so
systemic racism being injected into the
system by the anti-racists i know you
guys get it already
but then it's also really affecting it's
not just like the system-wide thing it's
this is at the most personal level how
you as a white person
should behave when you're in a specific
space
how you should speak how you should act
what motions you should make
who you should talk to when you should
talk to that you should be
somehow less than other people by poc
people you're not going to believe this
crazy
crazy theory i have everyone regardless
of their skin color should be treated
equally
everyone's opinion is as valid as anyone
else's everyone
has a right to be heard and right to be
respected
and all of those things and if you treat
me with respect i will treat you with
respect
but this here is bow
forever i am pharaoh bow
to me hebrew and it did not work for
moses
and i don't think it's going to work for
a lot of white people soon enough i mean
i think in essence what you're seeing
here
is you're seeing a select group of young
people who've been infected by the mind
virus of vocism
that are buying this but i am starting
to see more and more people
stand up i am sensing that there is a
little bravery moving along it's coming
around
and and if you go anywhere
if you go anywhere and you behave
differently or don't speak up
or whatever it might be because of your
skin color if you think that other
people
are better than you automatically or
deserve more respect than you
automatically because of your skin color
you got a real problem and it ain't your
skin color you got a psychological
problem and we got to deal with it and
that's why this
thing is a mic a mind virus
it is a mind virus and it must be dealt
with viruses very easy to catch hard to
get rid of
and we got to deal with this and
speaking of mind viruses
you know this 15 minimum wage thing that
we've been debating forever
right bernie's always pushing for a 15
minimum wage bernie has never run a
business bernie's actually never really
accomplished anything in government if
you look at his record
he has like one bill with his name
attached to it has something to do with
a post office or something
he's never done anything than usher in
sort of the worst socialist ideas that
are now undermining
the entire system so i'll give you
credit for that bernie with your three
houses and your
you know over a million dollars of worth
uh i will give you credit where credit
is due but he's always screaming about
15
minimum wage and you may remember about
a year ago
when rashida talib who's one of the
worst of the squad and the woke far left
marxist nut bags in the democratic party
uh when she was saying well in essence
why not 20 or 25
and it's like well actually rashida
you're kind of right because bernie just
made up 15. there's no
there's no economic theory that says you
can just
make up how much you have to give to
people and then all companies have to do
it
and then things will thrive right people
will not thrive because of that because
certain businesses won't be able to do
it it'll be much harder for small
businesses right so when they tell you
15
minimum wage who's going to who's that
going to hurt more is it going to hurt
amazon
or is it going to hurt mom and pop who
maybe were paying you know a high school
kid eight dollars an hour
to do something or a young person who
wants to get experience
so is willing to take less money because
their job is not worth
15 minimum wage and this is where the
market tends
to correct things right and by the way i
don't think that all business owners
and uh all people who create jobs one
way or another i don't think they're all
evil people have this idea that they're
sort of all
evil montgomery burn style capitalists
that want to destroy everything and
abuse everybody
i don't believe that i actually think
that most people who start businesses
want to treat their employees fairly
because if you really think about it in
a holistic way
the better you treat your employees the
more you pay them if you take care of
benefits or whatever else you might do
they're going to work harder for you
i'm sitting here with two of my
employees i try to treat them well both
financially and otherwise
so that they will work harder and guess
what when they work harder it helps me
that then enables me
to do more for them it's a beautiful
system capitalism if you let it work
but we've put this idea of 15 minimum
wage there which in effect will destroy
small business which is exactly what the
democrats want to do
by the way and now even the chipotle cfo
is saying that something ain't right
here and we've got a quote from the
blaze
while speaking on a quarterly earnings
call last wednesday
hartung said that chipotle executives
would
raise menu prices to offset the costs
the restaurant would incur if the
federal government forced them to pay
each of their nearly 90 000 employees
at least 15 an hour so just think about
this for a second everyone loves
chipotle okay we had it last week
i get my guys lunch by the way every day
that we work here i buy my entire team
lunch every day
i pay for it i'm happy to do it you guys
can't always get the extra avocado
though it's enough already with the
avocado
but the point is that he's saying in
essence we've got 90 000 people we have
to look at the numbers if we raise
all of their salaries to 15 per hour
we are going to have to pass that cost
on that is not a cost effective way
to run a business now this is obvious
this is economics 101 again
guys read any thomas soul book please
we've got a further quote from jack
hartung who's the cfo of chipotle
we're not that far off like for example
a 15
number but let's say for example that
there's going to be an across the board
10 increase in our wages and that would
to offset with menu pricing that would
take us
to two to three percent price increase
we think
everybody in the restaurant industry is
going to have to pass these costs along
to the consumer or the customer
of course they will of course they will
if you if the government
which is not in the delicious chipotle
bowl business
says you have to do a certain something
and run our you
run your business our way even though we
in the government aren't good at
anything
imagine a government run chipotle okay
it would be pretty freaking terrible
okay
so of course then the businessman and
the people that are in
that go into business to create a good
product and then
make money and then do things with that
money and expand
capitalism and expand freedom and
opportunity and the ability for people
to make money and all of those things
the government which doesn't do anything
well puts restrictions on them and then
what do they do they have to screw
over the average person and by the way
how far do you think we are when was
last time you went into chipotle you go
into chipotle what happens
you got the whole counter there you say
i want my i got my beef
my barbacoa my chicken i want the brown
rice the white rice
peppers and onions i want this that sour
cream cheese okay and you're walking
down
basically a conveyor belt right and
that's that conveyor belt has a couple
people behind it and a guy chopping
chicken in the back
and doing something with the cilantro
and then there's somebody
over there you know taking your credit
card at the end i don't even know if
they take your credit card anymore you
probably just put your
credit card in but in essence these are
all jobs that obviously are very
replaceable and not only are they
replaceable by people who they could pay
less to
but they are replaceable by robots and
the robots by the way are coming
and skynet is going to be turned on and
yes we are going to have to fight the
liquid terminator
okay just as arnold schwarzenegger did
because the machines are going to turn
on
because at some point if you were
looking at the business and going well
wait a minute
actually to put together a chipotle bowl
i could have a robot do this i could
have a robot chicken you know cut and
everything
i don't even need a person at the
register because they could just tap
their stuff in
either on an ipad that we have there or
soon enough they won't even need that
because you just do it you'll just
literally walk into the store do it all
on your phone it's just going to come
out
and you'll have one guy in the back they
will have one guy in the back
who's in essence running the entire
thing and if you think that is
a crazy proposition or some sort of
lunatic future dystopia that i'm making
up
amazon right now has their they've been
running a couple test
stores which basically have no employees
in them and everything is done
digitally i went into one of these
stores about a year ago
there's pretty much nobody there it's
all pre-packaged everything
and you've got your phone and that's how
it will be now i'm not even saying
that that is all necessarily bad right
like
actually i go to my supermarket over
here and you know everyone at least here
in l.a like these are just still like
scared of their own shadow leftists
working everywhere with their masks and
everything else so i just want to punch
people
when i walk in so i wouldn't mind
actually going to a store where i
wouldn't have to see people that
wouldn't
be that terrible to me but the broader
idea here relative
to okay if you force us to do something
as long as this remains a free country
and i think we've got a little window on
that
well then we're going to do things a
little bit differently and we'll either
bring in robots or we'll fire people and
hire other people
or we'll move operations out of the
country or or
whatever close more brick and mortar
stores and just have kitchens that
operate just to be
uh you know basically warehouses for
ubereats to pick up food i mean there's
a million ways you could do this
and this is just once again the
government getting involved in something
that it should have
absolutely nothing to do with you guys
want chipotle for lunch
chipotle chipotle you want that extra
avocado
extra avocado all right today's the last
day with the extra avocado
uh all right guys we got one more for ya
because the pandemic is basically over
everyone realizes that it's over and
when i say it's over i don't mean that
kovid
does not exist actually there's there's
a huge spike of covid
in india right now i actually have three
members of my family that in the last
three weeks got covered
they all happened to live in the same
house they're all okay they were all
sick for two or three days
they did a little self quarantine
everyone's okay was it worth
destroying the earth and human existence
for that in the last year and a half
if you're a democrat i guess the answer
is yes by the way not everyone three of
them live in the family
uh with the father he didn't get sick
i'm being specifically vague here
um specifically vague it's a good title
for a book
um but the point is they were sick for a
few days
drank a little oj took some meds
everyone's okay
all right so when i say that it's over i
mean the point is we should be living
our lives right now you should not be
wearing a mask outside
if you so choose to wear a mask indoors
that should be up to you
if you want to get a vaccine that should
be up to you as i keep saying
the vax people the people telling
everyone to get vacs is much like
dr uh frauchie franchi fauci
um much like that guy they're becoming
the anti-vaxxers because they're telling
you to get vaccinated and also avoid
crowds and keep wearing masks okay
so i would say i'm less of an
anti-vaxxer than fauci
is i don't really want the vaccine i see
no reason to get the vaccine
now eventually the entire system could
come crashing down on every
free-thinking individual
and basically say well we're not going
to give you bank accounts anymore we're
not going to let you travel
and if that sounds crazy to you i mean i
don't know that you're really tracking
what's happening in the world right now
but in any event i would say this thing
in essence is
over in that we should just basically be
ignoring
our our politicians at this point that
would be my personal view and i'm
allowed to state my personal view
in the united states of america here in
california we're still not fully
reopening until
june 15th because gavin newsom is a
[ __ ] dirtbag piece of [ __ ]
but let's get to some numbers and some
other stuff because
texas is fully open and florida is fully
open and i believe in some stores and
stuff you know they're making decisions
as to whether you're going to wear
things but
my parents are in florida right now
things have been basically open
everybody's happy
this is from fox news republican-led
states including texas and florida
are reporting fewer coronavirus cases
than michigan
pennsylvania and new york all of which
are led by prominent democrats who
refuse to roll back covet 19 regulations
and statewide mass mandates together new
york
michigan florida pennsylvania and new
jersey accounted for
44 of all new infections between march
29th and april 4th
with about 197 500 cases
out of around 452 000 seen nationwide
michigan has faced worst in the nation
covet 19 positivity rates in recent
weeks
the state reported 390.2 cases
oh that must be 390 000.2 right
no no i'm sorry it's 390 cases the 0.2
threw me there 390 cases
of the virus per 100 000 in the last
seven days sorry about that
governor gretchen whitmer has laid blame
on spring break travelers going to
florida urged residents
returning from the sunshine state to
work from home for a week
or have their children learn remotely
for a week uh it did turn out you may
have seen this that actually
whitmer while she was locking everybody
down and you may remember right at the
beginning she didn't even want people
gardening in the their own houses you
know in their own
yards and things she went to florida in
the midst of all this and if you want to
break the scandal on whitney
whitmer you know we've got the scandal
on cuomo it's like he sent the people
back into the
into the nursing homes and i think
there's a special place in hell for
andrew cuomo
but whitmer it's like have you seen this
lady's face i mean lady she's obviously
got botox and fillers i don't care about
that right i live in hollywood i mean
it's like the
it's like walking you going to a store
in hollywood it's like walking into the
cantina scene in star wars with these
with the faces of these people
like this right um but you want to break
the scandal on whitmer it's obvious that
she's gotten her
whatever it is she's doing to her face
she's obviously gotten that done in
during this last year and a half
whatever touch-ups and refreshers
she's doing so somebody whoever has been
injecting her face let's break that
scandal maybe that'll take her down but
the point is
without making this about whitmer or
newsome or anyone else that the states
that are opening up
are letting people live and these people
have just no
right to control us anymore they have no
right to control us and the only thing
that gives them the right to do it is
our acquiescence you know what i mean
like
that is what's giving them their power
it's not edicts that they're signing or
laws that they've put in place or
anything else it's that after a year and
a half
they broke people they really really
broke people
and people are still walking around with
masks outside
and we must push back and the only way i
think we can push back right now
i think there will be some political
answers to this and you guys know my
feelings about ron desantis
and greg abbott in in texas but for now
the best thing you can do is
just live your life and ignore these
freaks and leave them to their own
misery
and in a weird way maybe what we'll have
maybe we will start having two parallel
societies in america one will be the
society
that is obsessed with wokeness and
diversity and
lockdowns and mass mandates and constant
control
and being afraid of your own shadow and
then what will grow
right alongside of it is this beautiful
parallel society
where people will believe in individual
responsibility and taking care of
yourself and your family
and new technologies and crypto
and like all of the stuff that will get
us out of
this mess instead of being reliant on
people who would rather
us live like hamsters no offense to
hamsters by the way actually we had a
dinner party
uh i was perhaps at somebody's house
socially distanced with masks on friday
and their kids had a hamster i haven't
seen a hamster in years
but they had the hamster and the
habitrail and the whole thing what a
world what a world that's completely
fictitious by the way
uh part one of my interview with mark
levin who of course is the
the conservative commentator radio
legend
gajillion best time uh best-selling
author and all that good stuff
part one's up right now i really really
enjoyed talking to him not only
on like some of the technical stuff like
is there a difference between say
classical liberalism and libertarianism
and in many ways
is that any different than conservatism
right now but he's an expert
in marxism he's working on a documentary
about it right now
we really dive deep onto a lot of the
idea stuff i i really really enjoyed the
interview
part one is on youtube right now you can
get the full thing ad
free at reubenreport.locals.com right
now and by the way if you didn't know
that we always put
the full episodes up they go up on
mondays
that's five days earlier than they go up
on youtube so they're always there at
reuben report.locals.com
uh and by the way i am traveling for the
next couple days i'm going to
the free state of tennessee tomorrow i'm
going to be in nashville for the next
three days so there'll be no direct
messages this week although i will be
back on friday
for a friday bonanza round table i will
be
on candace owens new daily wire show on
friday night that's one of the things
i'm doing
in nashville maybe maybe maybe we could
try to do a reuben report meetup if
you're in our locals community we did
one
uh in oc last week which was awesome
about 70 people showed up lots of
tequila it was a good time
uh so yeah candace show nashville
no dm's in the next couple days i think
you guys will be all right have a great
day everybody
and oh and i'll you know follow me on
social media and i'll post pictures of
stuff
because that's what you do in 2021 all
right later
you